wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
so ein idiot über einen hoffentlich
nicht mich nein tut mir leid
haben sie schon mit herrn kurz
gesprochen ich ärgere mich immer wieder
ja schon gut wir fragen uns alles haben
sie jetzt ein moment zahlt ich wollte
doch etwas mit ihnen besprechen
ja es gibt im nächsten jahr eine
mieterhöhung die miete wird ab januar
teurer
dass man sie nicht ernst glauben sie
etwa dass er für immer den gleichen
preis zahlen können der markt verändert
sich die preise auch ich zahle genug und
sie haben schon vor zwei jahren meine
damit ich kann verstehen dass sie sich
nicht über die mieterhöhung freuen frau
gonzalez aber ich diskutiere nicht
mitgehen
wissen sie eigentlich dass viele kleine
laden sitze ihre geschäfte schließen
müssen weil die mieten immer teurer
werden das ist tragisch aber es
interessiert mich nicht
ja das wundert mich nicht menschen wie
sie interessieren sich nur für sich
selbst
ich werde auf keinen fall bezahlen
[Musik]